it thrilled your job
do not
a drill to work on women things so if
your drill is working on one thing it's
due to you it's my understanding the
drill so your drill you're tired of Hank
always a matter of you know
okay he pushes and I turn when he pushes
that's a single element and it's not
enough you're not conditioning in your
body your sinews your fashion and none
of that is happening you're not
understanding for example he comes in
and this time the timing of the initial
step so forget what you're doing with
your hand just so he comes in right boom
that that's the strike
he comes in that understanding that tiny
web where he's going to hit that sweet
spot of no base I have my base and boom
and I can hit him that that's all in the
first step and it has almost nothing to
do with title can't go as far as the he
pushes a nun you twerk you you could
have made just walked in you could have
made this drill and you're doing that's
the same sweet spot boom when I hit it
then I have to want to understand elbow
power so if I take my elbow out of it
like this my elbow doesn't doesn't do it
I just locked it here and then I keep
everything in the wrist and I have this
weird wrist lock thing going
I want to anchor it in space I don't
want to set it I where it is where I'm
going to be okay
and that is connected to my frame oh and
so that I have my elbow power not this
where up my only goal is to get around
him
here is connect
my elbow it's heavy that's how I'm
moving
so what when you do dude you have one
animal it's horizontal the more you can
stick in so here I have my angle
translation by angle disturbance my
double power my body movement
here's my tiny step of evening and I get
a lot of reaction out of it and then I
go up to chewed on turn my wrist I
reduce the amount of elements pass
through everything and you're doing on
and on and you go to change
if God was lower than that hole it shoot
dogs middle-level there must be some
lift in him right
you
it's like I'm doing distal and leopard
trim right these are my wrists
you'll find that there's a lift right
there is a lift of cheetah so I'm not
lifting him with my hand comes out she
already got lifted you see and now I'm
falling into place
I have the singing elbow in tension
it's all in my elbow power you get your
attention
so each one whatever you're doing some
of them are different I have to learn to
blend with the closing of this fingers
and the initial intention which cannot
happen with my hands still in space my
hands still in space right is a point of
contention that's setting up the problem
of the technique so if I don't do
anything to my hand then I'm going to
have that clock
you know I understand that so my hand
boom
why does he's come into her
oh no and you can't get around it by
moving your hand like that
this disability to blend with his
initial attention and the fingers is
where your pairing habits are you're
learning it right in there
when you do it like this
you're not going to learn it so it goes
okay
you
oh my it's got to have enough connection
where he will condition my body
so if people's let's that disconnects
that you don't get you're not gonna get
it
you
you should not take a parallel angle
where you're moving that way and he's
moving that way and then you're going to
catch up to him that's not what's
happening so here you have already a
variation on that he's not going that
way you understand he's going that way
so as I come around like that then I
don't go that way
he's going that way and I go this way
and then I miss him he's going around me
so I have to go around that leave center
point you understand that so I'm not
going here we're going around on the
point in space about there okay right
where this Kazushi angle is that's where
we're going
so I'm attacking him I'm not deviating
and hoping to catch him
I am aggressive motion which goes back
to my front foot so home okay let's
you